[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah great great they did one of
the best comedy sets I've ever seen it
was really really
you know No Holds Barred nothing off the
table which of course how can you be
funny if there's things you can't talk
about yeah all that comedians ever do is
talk about things they're not supposed
to talk about yeah I mean the nature of
Comedy is to talk about the stuff you're
not supposed to yeah definitely Darkness
that's the funny bits like that's where
it's like when you're a kid at school
you're like we're not supposed to say
this right now yeah it's not the
functional kind of the gessa was sort of
the important part of the court I
thought yeah undermine something the
only one that could tell the truth
that's how you know a tyrant man Tyrant
can't stand his own gesture yeah right
and so when you see people I think
there's two marks of tyranny right now
people who hate comedians people who
hate automobiles right really it's like
man that's a line of War for me it's
like keep your hands off my [__] car
yeah right prick yeah yeah well it you
think about what a car stands for it's
like radical autonomy and privacy right
right and that's a problem too with the
centralized control systems on cars now
you know we'll help you out with your
OnStar it's like yeah you'll govern
where I can drive you'll govern how fast
I can drive you'll end up bloody well
reporting me if I exceed 55 and destroy
the planet no I really don't like those
centralized control systems at all I
think they're a big mistake because as
soon as they're put in it's like those
since centralized control systems for
people's home heating well we'll help
you save Bill save on your bill until
until you're looking further down the
road of where where they're going with
it like like so for example when social
media started it was the place to upload
pictures yeah but now it's a way to try
and influence how we
feel about things sure well it's the
same with digital currency it's like
we're all making America we'll make a
currency and then we'll tax everything
that you purchase that we think has a
carbon load and that's you know you can
just bloody well be sure that the behind
the scenes globalists are just rubbing
their hands about that so can you
imagine what would happen if the
government could track everything you
bought Jesus Christ it's a real it's
that dream though isn't it yeah well
they'll do it for our own good yeah it's
amazing how many uh people can get away
with things when that's the illusion
yeah behind the message that's for sure
yeah I I remember feeling when we did
the lockdowns and that just feeling like
because I'm I'm
I feel like I'm not as controllable as
the average yeah you don't you don't
look like kind of lockdown guy no I'm
gonna try see what happens I definitely
felt like a a caged animal uh for a bit
there and I'm actually quite a homebody
so I you would have thought I would have
uh pissed it as we say in the UK yeah uh
but it was just the outrage within me
like why are more people not pissed off
outraged about the fact of we're being
told it's for our own girl yeah and
don't get me wrong that may well have
been the case like I was open yeah I
don't think there doesn't seem to be any
evidence that it was helpful it was no
proof of anything offered there was no
and if you did erase your head up and go
yeah I got a couple of questions about
this it's like you wanna you want people
to die you know and and that's that is
how they seem to control us whether it
be with comedy whether it be with
whatever that is always the message of
well this is for your own good and if
you're in the weaponization of guilt you
get the the radical types are so good at
weaponizing guilt people have got to get
over that and they're not themselves as
like the um the victim and that you are
the perpetrator yeah every time and when
we talk about comedy before she was
sitting down something else broke my
mind it was like
how people are always
um fake outraged you know what I mean to
try and take you down and and you've
probably you've dealt with that yeah
quite a lot yeah you might say the uh
social justice Warriors and whatnot and
what what is it um what is the thing
that I always get annoyed by what do
they call it virtues virtue signal and
stuff like that yeah yeah we can talk
about all of that today that'd be just
fine yeah well it's uh The Virtue
signaling thing that can use a fair bit
of unpacking because there's a real
technical reason that occurs and
um it does pose it poses a continual
threat to the Integrity of of society at
large it's narcissists
and Machiavellian Psychopaths they call
that the dark Triad those people are
very very good at
uh sending up camouflage that makes them
look like they're useful and productive
right and that's actually their strategy
you see that a lot with these guys that
are like women's rights Advocates and
they go to the protests that often women
where women often predominate it's like
oh yeah you're here on the women's side
are you uh-huh what sort of character
you are what sort of character is a good
question the Predator right like a real
Predator it's like oh I'm on your side
you know and maybe you'll climb into bed
with me it's very difficult to call that
out in a sense though isn't it because
how do I don't know they're the white
knight in shining armor in that instance
right if you're because you had an
attack video done on you in a similar
sense so what is that why why do you
think people do that to elevate
themselves falsely in the status
hierarchy so that they're more
attractive to well to women but also so
that they have a position among men that
they don't deserve instead of earning it
right they just fake it it's all
manipulation and they call it the people
who are good at that are part of the
dark Triad of personality traits
Machiavellian Psychopathic and
narcissistic
and so that's it's a form of camouflage
fakery
so it's like a guy who will you know
dress above his stature economically now
that's a much less toxic example of it
because that can be aspirational too
right he's trying to look better so he
can clue in but
um the the pickup artist types for
example they tell their Advocates to
Peacock to dress above their status
level and the reason they do that is
because then they can signal competence
that they don't have right because your
your style of dress is a marker of your
social status and there's for men and
for women there's lots of different ways
of doing that because it depends on
which hierarchy you want to be placed
properly in
but
you signal with your dress your status
and so then you can falsely signal
and you do that so that people are more
impressed with you than you deserve and
so it's a cheap way to gain reputation
and there isn't anything more important
to people than reputation and so really
that virtue signal signaling is false
reputation signaling
and it's a form of deception it's a deep
form of deception and social media
enables it like mad because the muscles
are stupid in my opinion A lot of the
time and they just fall for it they
don't say it it's a funny thing it's
because it is a kind of willful
blindness and sometimes it's a kind of
ignorance but once you have a society
that's basically based on trust and our
societies are basically based on trust
then people can exploit that trust right
they can act as if they're trustworthy
agents honest agents and gain the
access and opportunities that you could
gain reasonably if you were honest but
you can do it in a completely deceptive
way and I really do think the social
media networks in particular have
massively expanded that problem
because you as a as a narcissistic and
predatory Outsider your voice can be
magnified like mad all this trolling
behavior on on on on social media
comment sections in particular it's so
pathological it's like well you know
what it's like and you guys have
experienced this absolutely people will
say things in the comments section on
YouTube that would absolutely 100 get
them punched instantly if they ever said
it to your face yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's
so interesting eh because if they were
face to face with you yeah exactly they
wouldn't dare utter a word like that but
as soon as you put people especially
people who can't control themselves and
who are resentful as soon as you put
them behind a wall in some sense they
can well they can say whatever they want
to whoever they want and get away with
it I think I've been targeted a little
bit more because of kind of how I big
guy all of that I think people get a bit
of a thrill out of almost like Pokemon
course yeah like shouting at the line
through the cage a little bit you know
like it and especially I think that's
made me more of a Target without a doubt
in the last sort of few years yeah they
do the same thing to Dan Crenshaw he's a
congressman in in Washington he's a
tough guy he was in Afghanistan he lost
an eye in combat like Dan's tough guy he
was Navy SEAL and the controls come
after him like mad it's like oh there's
a war hero poke poke poke it's like yeah
poke him in person and see what the hell
happens but no no it's really it's hard
way of living your life it's so sad um I
don't presume we're on are we no we are
yeah we are yeah sorry yeah it's all
good
no no no no no that's fine I mean I kind
of feel like you don't need an
introduction with all due respect uh
Jordan you are uh probably the most
viewed podcast guest in history at this
point all right God that's a terrifying
thought that was quite amazing yeah well
done to you you know and you've done
that on content not on uh not on on
virtue signaling well you know you've
done it on to me what what content is
supposed to be about which is quality
and and you know not that everyone
should agree all the time and I'm sure I
mean I might not have agreed with
everything you've said but you're
bringing opinions and important
information at the table rather than
just uh bubble gum for the people out
there yeah well we're trying real hard
and not to be a Content Mill you know
and I have this new deal with daily wire
plus which seems to be going very well
and they're more corporate than me
because I'm just me and I have some
people around me obviously but there's
always a tendency once something gets
established you know and and it gets to
be a bit of a schedule behind it as well
and then maybe say a corporate uh
expectation you can easily get pulled
into the content Mill thought process we
have to produce something for of this
length for this time it's like it's very
very hard to avoid that one of the
things that's so nice about YouTube
because it's it doesn't have to be done
exactly to a schedule and there's no
bandwidth limitation is you don't have
to be dragged into the content mail
process you know I went to a lot of
Television interviews much less in the
last few years but when I started to
become more popular and it was always it
was so interesting going into TV studios
because I always felt like a product
and that's how the interview is
generally treated me too yeah and they
were often sound bites a couple of
minutes right you're just there to fill
a gap but that is what you were there
for because it was a mod that had to be
fed constantly especially with broadcast
TV because they had they had to fill all
the time and so what they filled it with
in some sense became subordinate to the
fact that it needed to be filled and
that's partly what accounted for the
falseness of Legacy Media because well
it turned into a Content mail and you
can see that happening with comedians
too you know he'd get some edgy comic
and then they'd get hired to write a
sitcom
and then the sitcom would be pretty good
but then they had to produce the damn
half an hour every week for like five
years and man that's a lot of content
and so it kind of it tended to kill the
goose that laid the golden egg I mean
some some series managed that really
effectively The Simpsons was pretty damn
good for about 15 years which is a hell
of a run and then not even too bad after
that yeah but it seems that it's kind of
run its its course recently I've watched
some recent years and starting to be a
parody of The Simpsons instead of The
Simpsons you know it's a little bit like
um actually he's another Canadian
martial McLaren said like um yeah medium
is the message people just get put into
the medium and they just then become
subject to it almost yeah well that yeah
that was really mcluhan's point was that
just when a new technology arises don't
be thinking that first of all that you
understand the technology or that it's
merely a replacement for the previous
technology I I see this with Legacy
Media companies that try to use YouTube
CBC the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation is a good example they just
can't get any traction at all on YouTube
and the reason for that is they think
YouTube is just TV except not as good so
first of all they have contempt for
Their audience right it's like oh
YouTube that's for you know trolls and
and narrative Wells misogynists and
bigots and racists and people on The
Fringe like Joe Rogan On The Fringe you
know because they are foolish enough to
think that someone like Rogan Is On The
Fringe which I think is really funny and
so when CBC started to put them put
their content like news clips for
example on YouTube they put up 10
minutes of content and with three
minutes of ads at the beginning three
minutes three minutes and you couldn't
skip them and then they disable comments
it's like you guys don't understand this
medium at all it's like you get one ad
15 seconds long people have to be able
to skip it and you don't get to disable
comments it's like who do you think you
are well we're CBC it's like yeah well
that's why you have like no viewers
because you roundly deserve it but we
all sing those mainstream broadcasters
uh even in the UK which I feel is behind
America they're pivoting and they're
learning quickly like okay this is how
we have to control people from this side
of things now we have to like tap into
this new generation like we've got
Sports companies ripping off our
concepts for example that are run by
billionaires and even um I think the
thing that really surprised me recently
was the royal family uh the funeral of
the queen
I thought no pun intended but that whole
thing was dead and buried I thought that
uh it was a thing that my generation
would not necessarily care about be
impacted by
um because they are so behind the times
and it they are so irrelevant to our
day-to-day lives in the UK and yet the
amount of people online who were sharing
pictures of the queen and all that and I
was like if I said to these people what
what did she do that was so great that
impacted your life in any way not a clue
but but people just go with the Floyd
and that's the sort of thing that is
surprising about I think it's generation
I think there is a buried value in the
queen that that wasn't as evident a
month ago let's say as it is now you
know so one of the tenets of
psychoanalytic idea uh let's say both
from the Freudian and the union
perspective is that
there's a poll towards the missing
opposite and so imagine a culture is
devoid of some sense that they actually
need so for example our culture is
pretty devoid of a sense that
responsibility is the counterpart of
Rights so everybody clamors about rights
but hardly anybody talks about
responsibility and that doesn't work out
because
rights the rights of someone else are
everyone else's responsibility so you
can't have
rights without responsibility so if you
only talk about rights half the
conversation is missing and the queen
she's a very interesting person because
she was very discreet she very rarely
shared her opinions and so that's that's
definitely missing in our culture she
was very dutiful she had celebrity
thrust upon her because well she
shouldn't there was no reason for her to
assume when she was young that she was
ever going to be Queen and because she
wasn't
close enough in the succession line for
that to be likely and then it happened
anyways and then
she's also been there for a very long
time which is interesting in a culture
that values the short term and she also
managed to keep her family together now
of course the family was fractious but
you know like find a family that isn't
fractious good luck with that and so and
then she also stood for tradition and
the British tradition and she also stood
for the English speaking people and the
Commonwealth and there's a that's of
course that's all being attacked on
grounds of colonialism Etc and
exploitation but like there's a genuine
gold core to the English
Enterprise especially with regard to
such things as common law and the and
individual rights and the Dignity of the
human being that shouldn't be thrown out
along with the criticism and so when the
queen died
people felt a loss of something they
didn't even really know was there and
that loss was the call towards these
more modest and responsible virtues that
she embodied can I can I just have
interest then
because I understand I think I
understand that I'm not a monarchist but
I understand what people believe she
embodied yeah I guess on a Counterpoint
to that but respectfully yeah her son
also did something that was quite
horrific as far as I'm concerned and she
abused that power to protect him or at
least it feels like it was an abuse of
that power so she definitely used her
Sway in the media to protect them and
yeah and she was very smart with the
media what are you referring to
specifically um so Andrew and you know
obviously we can't put too fine a point
on that because of uh people are quite
litigious but you know we know roughly
what the events were that happened there
and we know that people were paid we
know that people were paid to be either
be quiet or
you know not to get too deep into the
story or not to go to court and we know
he's not necessarily welcome in America
without the FBI waiting for him to get
off the plane with that I guess I I
respect what people believe she
represents and I'm I guess I'm quite
reverent of what she represents yeah but
also there was a sheer abuse of power
there that goes well beyond what anyone
else well you know do you know what I
mean yeah of course well look so part of
what's happening on our society at the
moment that's tearing it apart is
um constant accusations of the abuse of
power and so there's a Doctrine that's
come out of post-modernism and it's kind
of Unholy alliance with Marxism and the
doctrine is something like
all motivation can be traced to power
that's a very toxic Doctrine the
doctrine that all motivation can be
traced to power and so let me outline
that a little bit so a lot of people
think that there's a debate about who
should be allowed to speak in our
society right so we might think about
that as the Free Speech debate and we
might think about Council culture as the
attempt to stop certain people from
exercising their right to free speech
but that is not what the debate is about
that's only the paint on the surface of
a very thick wall let's say because the
actual debate is more like this
the post-modern types especially if they
have a Marxist tilt and they almost
always do their critique was much deeper
than that their critique was that the
idea of free speech itself
is a lie
and it was a lie that was created by the
powerful to justify their exploitation
by pretending that they valued free
expression and the Dignity of
individuals and so even though it sounds
like a profound and positive
proposition the idea that people have
the right to free speech it was nothing
but a mask
for power and so when people are
canceled on campus by this system of
ideas because it's really a system of
ideas in some sense that cancels them
the reason they're canceled is because
so here's why you and I are talking
according to this Doctrine you have a
following it as a consequence of that
following you've accrued a certain
amount of power you can bring me in here
as a tool let's say to ratchet yourself
up the status hierarchy you can act like
we're sharing information in a way that
might be designed to Enlighten both of
us and our readers or our listeners but
in reality all you're doing is trying to
elevate yourself up the status hierarchy
and if you don't know that you're just
ignorant and if you're and and blind and
you're even more dangerous than you
would be if you were conscious of your
true motivations and so it's all about
power now that's just not true it's not
all about power and in fact if you try
to govern your relationships based on
power your true relationships you will
fail so imagine that you you your wife
let's say
you're going to just use power to to
interact with her well
try it and see what happens you know
you're going to be she's going to be
miserable and she's going to be
resentful for sure and maybe she's got
more power than you when push comes to
shove who the hell knows women aren't
that easy to oppress and so they have
their own bag of tricks that's for sure
and so but at minimum you're going to be
setting yourself up for a Loveless
relationship based on Mutual suspicion
and then imagine you tried to use power
on your kids well now and then you might
have to use discipline
you might have to lay out the game rules
which isn't the same as like
constraining them with oppression and
but if your fundamental relationship
with your kids is one of dominance
you're just a tyrant and then if you try
using that on your friends well first of
all you won't have any friends the best
you'll ever manage is henchmen and
they'll only be around you because they
think they can get something out of your
power so they're the worst kind of
friend because they're not even
confident enough bullies to be bullies
on their own they have to hide behind
another bully and be sub bullies and
that's a dismal outcome and then if you
use power in your business relationships
it's like no one's going to be aligned
with you and the first time you make a
mistake
and and you show any sign of weakness
your so-called business associates that
you've just dominated because you have
the power they're just going to stab you
in the back and leave so it's a it's a
Preposterous Theory
it doesn't even work for chimpanzees so
the best work that's been done on chimp
so far being done by friends to wall
could be a very interesting guest by the
way he's very smart Dutch primatologist
if you have his number yeah I could
connect you
um DeWall has been studying chimpanzees
for three decades and he's written a
series of books about the emergence of
proto-morality in chimpanzees now chimps
have to live in a social group and for
decades and they have you might as well
call them friendships because that's the
closest analog and they have to maintain
those friendships and they can't
maintain them by dominance because well
then obviously it's not a friendship
they have to maintain it by mutual
grooming and caretaking and so what
dewal has shown is that the alpha chimp
so you think of the alpha chimp is the
roughest toughest Chimp in the troop you
know he's banging on sticks and
threatening everybody and he clambers
his way up the hierarchy just like the
marxists would assume and he established
is sexual superiority and propagates his
genes and the truth of the matter is
that's better than being weak and
useless and and dying but it's not
nearly as good as being genuinely
reciprocal and so what the wall has
shown is that sometimes the alpha chimp
male is the smallest male in the troop
so that's pretty damn interesting but
more to the point the alpha chimp is the
most reciprocal member of the entire
troop so he's keeping track of his
social relations he's grooming his
friends they're interacting constantly
like he's maintaining social
relationships like mad and there's two
advantages to that apart from the fact
that he attains a certain degree of a
reverence let's say an authority and and
some preferential sexual access so it's
a good biological strategy
the troop is oft also more stable
emotionally partly because it's not
ruled by a tyrant let's say who's always
disrupting things but
the alpha whose reciprocal also can have
a long Reign because if you're one of
those chimps that use
manipulation and Power
to climb up the hierarchy as soon as you
show a sign of weakness two of the males
that you've oppressed will get bang gang
together which chimps are very good at
and tear you into bits and so dewal has
written very frightening accounts very
graphic accounts of these like
revolutions against tyranny and chimp
groups and so the people who claim that
power is the only motivation they don't
have a leg to stand on it's just not
true and there's one one more one more
thing that goes along with that
two more things one is
if you think power is the only
motivation that's your whole Theory then
you're justified in using power at every
at every step because there's nothing
but power so why not use power and so
it's a confession more than an
accusation and second this is sort of
germane to your criticism of the queen
when systems deteriorate
power emerges as a fundamental
motivation and so part of the reason the
marxists and the postmodernists can be
so attractive in their critique is
because power does corrupt and so
whenever you look at any Enterprise
social Enterprise any family structure
even any relationship someone has with
themselves you can say well look to some
degree you're corrupted by misuse of
power and and sometimes that can go way
out of control right and be the dominant
uh the dominant phenomenon that happens
in totalitarian States and you say well
it's all about power well it is when
things get entirely corrupted but that's
a whole different proposition than
everything's based on power it's more
like well hold it everything corrupt
is based on power but but not everything
is corrupt and so so now if you look at
the monarchy well right and you think
okay well
how do you separate the wheat from the
chaff right how do you give the
institution it's due do you have the
same problem with the British Empire
let's say or with any expansive
political Enterprise it's like well it's
done some good what's the good and then
it's abused its power well how do we
decide what's good and maintain that and
and and and and and and value it and how
do we discern what's a misuse of power
and criticize it properly and dispense
with it you're a great thing that was my
follow-up question and you basically
just answer your question but I guess
that is that is are you acknowledging in
a sense then that there is a sense an
element of corruption around the queen
there's an element of corruption around
every everyone who isn't you know what
would you say walking hand in hand with
God in the Garden of Eden like right
look there's an old there's a
mythological Trope that's very useful in
understanding this presume that most of
the people watching and listening have
watched The Lion King The Lion King has
a very very solid narrative structure
it's a very smart movie like many of the
Disney movies and people criticize me
because I'm so interested in Disney
movies but I'm interested in anything
that many many many many people watch
for a long time because well what's
going on there why is that so attractive
and often a movie's attractive because
it gets the story right and the
characters write whatever that means
well The Lion King was a very very
successful animated movie one of the
most successful movies of all time for
those who can't remember
everything the light touches is our
Kingdom right yeah that means I can tell
you exactly what that means that that's
a brilliant line and that's also and
notice I used the word brilliant and
Brilliant is associated with the idea of
the light okay so now the when the light
touches something and you see it then
you establish a relationship with the
thing that you see because now you start
to understand it and the more lit up
something is the more you're you can
understand it and explore it and so when
you shine a light into dark crevices
then let's say then you start to see
what's in the dark crevices and if you
go around your apartment building let's
say and you pay attention to every nook
and cranny you start to it starts to
become yours in a very fundamental way
and so you can say well light is
equivalent to Consciousness that's a
good way of thinking about now why well
we're very visual creatures human beings
our brains are organized on Vision most
animals are organized on smell by the
way but not us we're organized on vision
huge part of our cortical activity is
devoted to to sight and so we think of
sight as Enlightenment light we think of
it as illumination right when we bring
something into the light we improve it
and so we associate the day with
Consciousness and illumination and
Enlightenment and so if you attend to
something by shining a light on it then
it becomes yours and so your kingdom is
actually everything that the light of
your Consciousness is shown on and all
that's encapsulated in that statement
and that's why it's stuck in your
imagination yeah you remember he's up
he's up with his son on a mountain right
on a cliff and so now think about that
that means he can see a long way and
then he sees this this circle of the
world and the light shining on it and he
says everything the light shines on is
our kingdom and then that also implies
that and he says that next that outside
the light there's another kingdom and
that's the kingdom of darkness and
that's the place that hasn't been
explored and if you remember in the
movie that's where that's where the
fascists are and the hyenas and the
hyenas are predatory and so when Simba
goes out past the domain of the light he
enters the unknown and he enters this
the Underworld the Demonic underworld
and that scar now back to scar okay so
so Simba has Mustafa as his father and
Mustafa is the positive aspect of the of
the patriarchy and he's wise and he's
tough he's got a set face he's no
pushover but he has an evil brother and
that Scar and Scar has been scarred and
that's why he's resentful right he's a
victim and and he feel he's a victim
because his brother gets all the
attention like Cain in relationship to
Abel and he's a victim because for some
reason we don't quite understand
but he's intellectual too right so he's
got the pr he's got luciferian he's got
the luciferian pride in intellect and
Jeremy Irons who is that character
played that extremely well with that
kind of unctuous voice that was kind of
like a snake
yeah well and also contemptuous and and
presumptuous and narcissistic he did a
lovely job of that and so now you might
say well why does the king have an evil
uncle or an evil brother well the answer
is this is the mythological answer is
that well the king always has an evil
brother always and the reason for that
is if the king is the emblem of the
state which or even of the stable state
of being because you can think about it
psychologically or sociologically he
always has a counterpart and the
counterpart is the proclivity of that
state to be overtaken by willful
blindness so failure to shine a light on
things right to turn your head away when
you know you shouldn't and also by this
corrupt will to resentful power and
that's chronic now the Marxist would say
and do in some real sense there's
nothing but scar there's nothing but the
evil Uncle it's like that's a hell of a
world view I can tell you in some real
sense it's Akin on the Christian front
to making the statement that the true
ruler of reality is the satanic spirit
it's the same idea and that's a hell of
a claim man to to literally speaking and
so
but but it is the case that almost every
institution and almost every person has
a touch of the evil Uncle as part of
their structure you know there's no
doubt that prince Andrew well
but everyone so imagine you imagine that
to some degree you're not as good an
advocate for yourself as you might be I
don't need to imagine that yeah okay so
you know that okay so then imagine
there's part of your character that's
sort of set against you yeah and it
would be set against you because well
you might doubt whether life has any
fundamental meaning and you might be
annoyed and irritated because you've
been hurt and betrayed in various ways
and your development of might have been
stunted because you hit obstacles and
you didn't explore them enough and so
your way was barred and and so there's a
part of your character that is set
against you and you have to contend with
that part and hopefully overcome it or
integrate it which is a better way of
thinking about it and then that's the
same for your relationship with your
wife and then that's the same for your
relationship with your kids and it just
scales all the way up and then you can
say well look
you're corrupt and the truth of the
matter is well you are to some degree
but the the to some degree is actually
the crucial issue here
I guess that's where my Chris we go back
to the criticism I guess I made of the
queen in the first place
um that's part of the problem with the
discourse around it I guess at the
moment or the conversation is if I
criticize the queen in the time when
we're mourning the immediate reply is
not the time yeah but that's always the
response with the queen and with Andrew
this is the time you know don't talk
about it like this and so there never
really seems to be a time but also at
the same time when I do have a
legitimate criticism people go well
you're an anti-monarist they know well
not necessarily I've just got a
criticism of what happens there so we
can't have a nuanced reasonable
conversation well people don't people
don't really like Nuance that much
because so well here's something I I had
a conversation with uh that with a great
physicist Roger Penrose and Penrose
um has this obsession with with Tyler so
he designs tiles and he's interested in
the mathematics of tiling and and it's
in some sense a strange interest and so
but he's a genius and so whenever I see
a genius and he has a strange interest I
think that's probably related to his
genius in some way because after all
he's a genius and so I thought a lot
about his obsession with tiling outside
the building he works in at Oxford the
the the the land outside is covered with
a tile that he designed that has certain
mathematical properties that I don't
know enough about to describe in detail
but I I was very interested
psychologically in the idea of tiling so
imagine that you have a surface on
uneven and rough surface that's very
complicated like an uneven rough surface
is it's extremely highly detailed right
and it's got undulations and it's made
out of dust and the dust is made out of
you know atoms at the finest level of
resolution well you can go even finer
than that it's very complicated any
surface now when you tile it you
simplify it right because each tile in
some sense is homogeneous that's sort of
what makes it a tile it's one piece so
you take this thing that's extremely
complex and you put a simpler
representation on top of it and so one
of the things I've learned about people
is that we all tile the whole Cosmos so
you have a model of the entire universe
now you think well how can you because
what the hell do you know and the answer
is you use really big tiles
so imagine what you know about uh
Serbia
you know you maybe you know a lot about
Serbia but I'm gonna assume you don't my
wife's from Kosovo so I know okay so
okay so but but then you think you know
a fair bit it's like well maybe you
could identify where it is located on a
map if you had a map you probably
couldn't drive and disagree with a few
people about what Serbia is and isn't on
a map okay well that's also a problem
but imagine you could probably point to
Serbia on a map but then I could say
well could you draw that map without
looking at a map could you draw a map of
Europe accurately without looking at it
now maybe you could but most people
certainly can't but they could rip but
they could point to it so imagine people
have a representation of the whole world
but it's really really really really
really
low resolution it's sort of you can see
this if you get people to do something
like well do you know what a helicopter
is it's like yes can you draw one so
they draw it looks like a three-year-old
drew a helicopter it's like it's got
rotors it's like four parts rotors
ball stick ball that's a helicopter it's
like no it's not
especially not if it's a military
helicopter I think you have to for a
military helicopter to fly you need 35
hours of maintenance for every hour it's
in the air and the reason for that is
well they're rocks like they're solid
piece of metal you know they just
plummet they don't fly and keeping those
things in there is really complicated
and you have to know the helicopter in
unbelievably great detail in order to
actually make it work and so when you
say you know what a helicopter is you
might say well what do you mean and your
answer is something like well I know one
well enough so that if I walk by it it
doesn't explode it's something like that
and so your representation is good
enough so that in your normal course of
Affairs you can use it to navigate
through the world and that's how you
adjudicate your knowledge and so if you
never go to Russia you can have a really
low resolution representation of Russia
and it doesn't matter now the devil's in
the details let's say you talked about a
nuanced conversation well let's say
you're an environmentalist well that's
what you say and that's claim to moral
virtue and you say okay well what do you
mean you're an environment well I think
we should serve the planet it's like
well what do you mean the planet and
what do you think the big
issue is well it's carbon it's like well
is it really
um what about overfishing what about uh
despeciation what about soil degradation
what about the idea that if you made
people richer they would become more
environmental environmentally conscious
and so maybe the best way to clean plant
it is by making the poor people Rich
which by the way seems to be the case
um and so on and what about setting
aside Marine protected areas what about
how much land should we preserve on
Earth so that we can grow crops
optimally but still maintain the Natural
Balance what how would you define Eco
diversity do you know many how many
species are propagating compared to how
many are going extinct and the answer is
you don't know any of that and so that
also means you're not an
environmentalist it also means that I've
just shown a light on your claim that
you're an environmentalist showing you
that it's unbelievably shallow and just
a false virtue signaling flag and so you
can't have a nuanced conversation
because what you do is you tell people
you say to people you're using a very
big tile
to cover an awful lot of snakes like
thousands of them or hundreds of
thousands of them and I'll just lift up
the tile
and show you the snakes and some of
those snakes are you and your pretension
that your tile actually constitutes
knowledge when it with it which it
doesn't and so if you have a nuanced
conversation and you show that you
understand the details at least to some
degree then you're a threat to the
Integrity of the person's world view so
you replace that Unity with a complex
and anxiety provoking multiplicity and
you also illuminate their pretension to
moral virtue and so it's no bloody
wonder they don't like you it's like oh
you said this is way more complex than
you think you have no entitlement to
moral virtue as a consequence of your
low resolution claim you do you you lift
up the lid a lot and you know you've got
security uh yeah I was wondering Good
Guys lovely man uh yeah they're really
good I was wondering
um
you know with all of The Shining of the
light that you've done on certain people
who hold very dear to their heart their
opinions and their virtues and all that
how bad it's gotten for you at times
because you become incredibly well known
and whenever that happens and I know
that they've came for you multiple times
but have you ever had any situations
where you thought I could deal with some
security here well we decided
um the the security thing is is an
ambiguous blessing let's say I mean my
security people who are who are tough
and competent people and alert
are not primarily used for security
around me they're primarily used for
Logistics because my days are very
packed and they're packed in a way that
requires very careful orchestration
primarily because I'm on a book tour and
there's a rule when you're on a tour if
you're doing two or three venues a week
of 4 000 people let's say and the rule
is you absolutely 100 percent have to be
at the venue early enough beforehand to
prepare so that the show goes on and
there's no room for failure on that
front because otherwise you annoy 4 000
people and that's just not acceptable
and especially if you're doing it
sequentially so things have to be timed
very carefully and while I'm doing that
in all the countries that I'm visiting
I'm also meeting with cultural and
political leaders constantly and so it's
very tightly scheduled and I can't do
that without
help and competent help and so I have a
lot of people who are doing things what
do they do well I never pay attention to
Transportation I always have a car
available and sometimes multiple cars I
don't have to pay any attention to
flights I don't have to pay any
attention to hotels I don't have to pay
any attention to restaurants I don't
have to worry about whether my wife is
doing okay because she has someone with
her if I'm not around and someone
helping her and the reason and my
security Logistics guys handle that and
I have a secretarial team that organizes
all of that as well and so
so that that was part of the
organizational because we learned on the
first tour back in 2018 my wife was
handling a lot of that and it was too
much and it wasn't it was all not
obviously sustainable right it was
wearing me out and it was also wearing
her out and one rule about being worn
out is well you're either being
egotistical because you think you can do
more than you can or you're taking on
too much responsibility which is also a
kind of egotism and a kind of
victimization and you're not delegating
enough which is also kind of greedy you
know because in my situation I have a
lot of opportunity and a lot of
privilege we could say and I I if I'm
wise I can parcel out some of that to
other people and then they have
something good to do and useful and
interesting and then they can be helpful
and the whole Enterprise can work better
and so
um now on the security front plane and
and simple
my wife and I talked about this last
year with my family and
um
my wife said John Lennon only got shot
once
which is
you know I mean I'm not comparing myself
to John Legend
well it only takes one person who's you
know uh banned and now
if you looked at my life online you'd
think that I was just being vilified
non-stop wherever I go and that's just
not true at all so all my interactions
with people in public with the tiniest
exceptions are extremely positive in
fact they're overwhelmingly positive and
so that's amazing that's amazing and
it's it's such an honor that that's the
case
um now and then maybe one in five
thousand encounters someone is hostile
um and I you don't forget that when it
happens because when someone you don't
know is hostile to you you don't know
where that might go and so it and it
happened once when I was with my son and
it happened once when I was with my wife
and once when I was alone and none of
those situations were dangerous but that
that doesn't mean that that you should
not pay attention to them or that
they're not stressful because if you if
some stranger just came up to you on the
street and started harassing you so
angrily and insultingly you have no idea
who that person is and they could be
anyone and that's that's bad when they
could be anyone because people can get
pretty damn demented and you can run
into someone who's crazy enough to light
themselves on fire just to send you and
so and I know what people like that or
like because I've seen many people like
that and so
we decided that we needed Logistics help
and we needed more eyes just attending
to everything that was going on you know
and I my security guys are very friendly
with everyone and they're very welcoming
and hospitable and and they're very
oriented towards that and then they're
very
adamant about getting the logistics
right because most of them are military
guys they're also very good at that kind
of you know detailed strategic
organization and so that's become
necessary to make this Enterprise carry
on in an effective way there's a bit of
a cost to that because but it's not
really avoidable I can't really go out
now anytime anywhere that's in public
and just have it be ordinary you know so
even if if I'm in Toronto and my wife
and I in our little neighborhood we walk
this little kind of little village in
the middle of the city if we just walk
down to the corner store to the local
pharmacy a couple of blocks the
probability that all gets stopped like
five or six times always positive is a
hundred percent and so everything turns
into a show in some real sense I
wondered what the cost was to you though
personally like on a on an emotional
level because
I think you're a bit misunderstood by
some people because it feels like uh
your goal is to help people overall
that's that's what always comes across
from you whenever I see you get
emotional and things I think this guy's
a good man
um and somewhere along the lanes uh
other people have managed to maybe
distort that message uh or maybe in
those long nuanced conversations you've
had with people like Joe Rogan a song by
has been taken out and that's been
thrown out there and that's the thing
that people that know you for and I just
wanted how how you're coping well the
the consequences of that online and in
the media is that I'm being chewed on on
a regular basis by people who are in
ranging in Social Status you know the
last thing was Olivia Wilde's
pronouncement that the villain in her
new movie was based on me and so which
was quite by that we we've had this
happen so many times now I mean by we my
family because we all kind of react to
this as a unit and we've learned how to
deal with it to some degree you know
because for a long time when something
like that happened it wasn't obvious
that it wasn't going it could have been
a disaster right because you can get
taken out and I mean by disaster when
this all this blew up around me disaster
initially would have meant I would lose
my professorship I would lose my
clinical license and and a huge chunk of
my ability to be viable financially now
I had three sources of income so and one
of them was Private because I have my
own company and have had for a long time
it's pretty hard to take me out
financially but
that was still the risk and then the
risk to my professional reputation when
this is all new to you at the time and
when things are blowing up and it's
first happening is from personal
experience the first times it happens
the more oh God out of control it feels
whereas yeah when you become battle
hardened it you know you get thick skin
obviously yeah well and you also learn
how these things work and way the way
they work now it depends on how stupid
the thing is that you did that you're
being attacked for because you might
bear some culpability right
and that's a tough thing to sort out so
the latest
one of the latest scandals I suppose
that I've been involved in culminated in
me being essentially ejected from
Twitter now really what happened was
they
they didn't like one of my tweets
um about uh this actress actor Ellen
slash Elliott page and uh because I dead
named her I suppose they never really
told me the reason but I presume that's
dead named you know because now that's
become a mortal sin
um because of the bloody trans activists
and anyways they
suspended my account unless I would
delete the tweet and I'm not deleting
the damn tweet and the Tweet has caused
a fair bit of tension among
some of the people I'd been
communicating with who are more on the
liberal and Progressive side because
they didn't like that tweet although I'm
not it was harsh
and
but I'm not sorry enough about it to
delete it so that's life you know that's
a boundary
but when you get attacked for that sort
of thing like being banned from Twitter
which became quite scandalous and more
evidence that I'm just a reprehensible
character
you have to first of all your conscience
goes after you right because if a bunch
of people come after you and say you're
reprehensible generally if that happens
it's because you're reprehensible that's
generally the and if you don't respond
to that in some way well then you're
you're kind of Psychopathic because you
don't care it's like I do care but that
doesn't necessarily mean that I'm wrong
just because people are upset and that's
definitely the case when Society has
become somewhat unstable your response
I'm I've been a uh I guess I first came
across you when uh during the time when
you were talking about um being
compelled to speak in a certain way in
Canada yeah it's a pronoun law yeah and
but then I read both your books I
thought they were fantastic books they
had a profound impact on me I found them
very interesting especially from a
religious perspective I found it very
interesting
um we both come from we're more I guess
we identify as atheists but I think it's
very it's your pronoun is one of them
um I think I'm agnostic you're agnostics
agnostic atheist you can never really
know to that extent but I found what you
were saying very interesting saying my
wife's Muslim will raise him now kids
Muslim so I guess there's an interesting
aspect of that but what I find difficult
I guess to justify I'm I'm speaking from
only my experience
I went to goldsmiths and you might know
goldsmiths is a quite a liberal Marxist
University in South London when I went
there I my experience was quite similar
to the way that you describe liberal
universities quite radical it's an
extremely radical University
um you know there's a strike every day
that's right yeah we have universities
like yeah there's always something
that's striking about I don't even know
what I never went to University but I I
know that about them
that's what they specialize in yeah
that's the thing I'm actually most other
than the women who went there but sure
the story so it definitely is so I guess
from my perspective I saw the merits I I
went to that University and I guess I
was a more Centrist uh in retrospect
before I went there uh I saw the Merit
of some of the things that the left say
and I saw some of the merits in
discussing Marxism and a lot of the
debates that we had at those
universities yeah in that time it really
opened up my mind in that time not that
I was particularly smart or anything but
it really opened up my mind
and sometimes I guess the struggle that
I have with speed speaking about you to
other people and my my circles will be
more liberal side
because of the aggressive uh
relationship you now have with some of
these circles it makes it a lot more
difficult for me to
open up some of what you're discussing
with those people so everyone's when you
say those bloody trans activists yeah
from my perspective that's a very broad
term for a lot of some people will
consider themselves low down on being a
trans activist some people will consider
themselves to be radical yeah how do you
how do you see that because well okay so
interested to know let's look at this
tweet this because I can't even see it
by the way I've just tried to see the
Tweet they've almost like blanked it do
you remember yeah yeah roughly I mean I
said it was in June this year and that's
pride month and as far as I'm concerned
pride is not a virtue and a month it's
like really a month really a month
Christmas is one day
well it could be 12. yeah true is a
month fair enough yeah but you know we
don't have public parades for Advent I
get what you mean right okay so so first
of all Pride yeah we're really
celebrating that are we because that's a
cardinal sin and it really is and I mean
really and month that's a little ear
pushing it guys so I said can I ask why
that's a cardinal sin because I'm a bit
in the docky I didn't well you're you're
agnosticated okay okay well it's because
look we're having a productive
conversation okay so how can we tell are
you interested in the conversation yeah
so am I is the time going by quickly yes
okay so those are good markers now
they're biological markers so imagine
that your nervous system is tuned
so that you find any experience that
puts you on the edge of development as
engaging
so imagine you're wrestling or you're
playing or you're in a sports
competition now you want to be matched
with someone who's about as good as you
or maybe even a little better and you
think well why if it's about Victory so
if it's about power why not find some
player who's nowhere near as good as you
and just Stomp Them and the answer is
well that's not fair that's one answer
and the other is well that's no fun it's
like well why is it no fun if the point
is the victory
and the answer is well the point isn't
the victory the point is well what is
the point well the point is the fun yeah
but what's the point of the fun well the
point of the fun is to Signal optimal
development and so that's the line
between yin and yang that's the line of
meaning and it's the line between Chaos
and Order and Chaos is where you don't
understand things at all
an order in its extreme is where you
don't understand as much as you think
you do right so it gets tyrannical and
so structure and lack of structure or
actuality and possibility now how do you
mediate between those two and the answer
is you have an instinct for that an
instinct is meaning and engagement and
your nervous system is signaling to you
we're not this conversation Isn't So
contentious that we're upset
and it's not so mundane that we're bored
it's right on the it's right on the
border okay so so
let's go back to the to the to the Tweet
the mean tweet so I said oh yes so why
is pride a sin okay so Pride's a sin
because humility is the precondition for
play
so the reason that we can have this
conversation and it's working is because
you know there are some things you don't
know
and I know that there are some things I
don't know and I assume that you might
know some things that I don't know
they're useful and vice versa and then
we can throw our mutual knowledge back
and forth in this Spirit of let's say
playful engagement and we can move
towards Mutual Enlightenment and
Redemption and I would say redemption
because well you're trying to redeem
yourself from your ignorance and your
blindness but you're also trying to
redeem yourself from your excessive
pride and your pride would be I know
what I'm saying I know what I'm doing
it's like what I know goes it's like
well maybe it's like is everything
paradiseled around you
is everything set in perfect order
around you and if the answer to that is
no well probably you have something to
learn and then you might say well what's
the attitude that signals that you have
something to learn and the answer is
technically the answer is humility and
that's the opposite of Pride and so
that's pride is a sin because it leads
you to be a tyrant and it stops you from
learning and then it also leads you to
you know it the Tyrant part is exercise
control over others because you're right
and so pride pride is one of the
cardinal sins along with like those two
things together are sort of the Nexus of
hell so like a totalitarian state is
prideful because the total totalitarians
say
well we already know everything it's
it's embodied in Marxist Doctrine we've
got the truth a hundred percent of the
truth and if you dare to oppose it
you're obviously an enemy because we
have a hundred percent of the truth and
so and not only do we have the truth but
our interpretation of the truth is 100
correct it's like really dogmatic well
unbelievably dogmatic and you know that
can manifest itself on the religious
front too and does quite frequently it's
why some it's often why people criticize
religious institutions any and all
institutions can tilt into that but
pride is the opposite of humility and
humility is the precondition for
Learning and you know you might say
that's partly why humility is something
that was practiced Say by genuine
religious people as a virtue because the
idea would be to open yourself up like a
child you know how open a child is to
learning well the child doesn't assume
he or she knows everything already
they're just looking around all the time
which is one of the things so remarkable
about children they're just looking
around all the time at everything they
don't know and with it with us like an
infant that's just they're just like
this all the time wondering what the
world's going on and trying to learn and
so Pride stops learning and so when I
see something like pride month I think
Pride that's not a virtue it's not a
virtue can I ask that could you let's
cut you off again that's okay so that's
only a little tiny fraction of the Tweet
exactly it's the confusion for me I
guess is when when I hear your reaction
to pride month I I personally have never
I'm not a gay guy and I don't really
have a lot of gay friends if I'm honest
with you so okay you know I mean we look
at each other occasionally a little too
long yeah yeah I've noticed that it's
quite sad yeah try it I mean we're like
work husbands uh for sure but um when I
say all over my social media The
Rainbows are everywhere you know I'm
kind of like yeah my life gets invaded
by it but it's not uh an inconvenience
to me I'm like I'll let them have it
well if it makes them happy like
whatever I don't it doesn't annoy me in
any way
um and when I watch your reaction there
it was kind of like oh I wonder why you
find that uh maybe more irritating well
it's just too much right that's why it's
like I agree with you so first of all
technically speaking
any social Norm has a Unity at the
center that's what makes it a norm or an
ideal and as a fringe at the periphery
and the category has to be loose enough
so The Fringe can be allowed to exist
but The Fringe can't take the center
because the center has to be a Unity or
it's not a center and so in our society
The Fringe keeps taking the center and
that can't happen because the vicinity
goes with the flow too much well it's
also because The Fringe feels alienated
because they're not at the center okay
but it doesn't matter but the center is
also I guess the center some people
would argue have become I I absolutely
this but yeah in a way but also become
quite lazy maybe a little bit sloppy in
the way that it was operating and some
people saw a bit of a void in that Unity
it always happens that's the evil Uncle
it happens all the time yeah yeah
LGBT people are evil uncles I mean the
center has an evil uncle right the
center is that well the center is a
little off-center and it's a little more
tyrannical than it should be it varies
of course it does and that's right it
varies from from from time to time
because the center has to move which is
a weird thing and the reason the center
has to move is because the environment
moves and it's like a snake and you've
got to keep up with it and so that's why
that's why dialogue is necessary because
the way that we adjudicate the center
the moving center is through logos
through dialogue so then how do you
that's I guess because I'm just thinking
like when you said earlier about the
evil uncle in in the way the center
moves generally speaking you said to say
people who want Power
like to say that they are always
tyrannical is yeah it's just not true oh
no but but does that not mean though by
the very nature of wanting to get that
that more of the percentage is leaning
towards being the evil Uncle generally
speaking no no well it depends on the
society it's definitely a risk I mean if
you look around the world most societies
aren't free right and you could you
could get a rough estimate of that just
by looking at well which societies
attract immigrants
and now that's just an obvious marker
right it's like do you want to live
there or not that's the fundamental or
do you want to leave where you are and
go there yeah you say well there isn't
perfect it's like fair enough it's right
it's better than where you're you're at
and so you can just rank countries by
how many people want to go there and you
get a rough estimate of who's got the
balance right and and so you might say
well
order keeps chaos under control
it's like yes but not optimally what
keeps chaos under control
first of all it's not under control it's
balanced that's a better way of thinking
about what keeps Order and Chaos
optimally balanced is something like
logos and I mean that Technically when
you have a dialogue so our dialogue is
engaging so dialog log means diet logos
it means two logos interacting so the
question is what's logos and logos is
something like the spirit that mediates
between Order and Chaos and and it is
why is it a spirit well it's a spirit
because it can inhabit you and it it it
produces a mode of being and the mode of
being is something like
lack of self-consciousness and deep
engagement and so that's the mark that
things are balanced and that's not a
tyrant it's it's the it's the very
opposite of a tyrant and it's not order
it's the phenomenon that produces
habitable order out of chaos and you can
tell when that's happening because it
happens if you're in a say a loving
relationship with your wife and and
there's that playful Dynamic that goes
along with that it happens when you have
the same with your kids it manifests
itself most clearly in the spirit of
play and so our discussion is somewhat
playful like we're pushing each other
we're trying to discuss things we don't
understand and there's a back and forth
but it's optimally balanced because
there's a bit of humor about it so
that's one of the ways you can tell it's
optimally balanced and with any luck
we're doing it well enough so that other
people who aren't part of the
conversation still find it engaging
right and so you can tell we've got
something right there not only is it
working for the two of us and the two of
us and the three of us but also so it's
working in a manner that works for us
that's working for other people so
there's a kind of Harmony harmonious
balance there that's sort of like music
and music's a good
uh representation of that that's why
people play music right because it's it
it marks the spirit of Play Because
musicians are playing with sound and
they do that in a harmonious way where
all the parts are related to one another
and are moving towards some point and so
music is a great representation of the
spirit of play it's the best
representation of the spirit of play I
think abstractly of all the Arts and so
that's the antithesis to power not not
it not
it it that's the right way of thinking
about it's the antithesis to power
especially corrupt power now back to
pride pride is an impediment to the
spirit of play that's a good way of
thinking about it pride requires the
imposition of force because if I'm if I
know what I'm doing and I'm trumpeting
that as well as something that marks my
identity above yours I'm proud of it
then I can't engage in dialogue I can't
be humble I can't open myself up to
Revelation let's say which because a
conversation is a form of Revelation
right because it's an interpersonal
communication I get access to you which
is quite something you know because you
it is paid for your experience with
hardship and you can tell me about that
and if I listen then maybe I won't have
to have a hardship that would be
necessary to Garner the wisdom how often
do you find that's the case because I am
I know I feel like a lot of the time
maybe people have told me while I was
young avoid this or avoid that and the
only time I've really learned it is when
it kind of happened to me it happened to
me well you know I think the less you're
willing to Die optimally the more it has
to be forced upon you by Fate you know
and so if you keep yourself updated
because you're looking in the nooks and
crannies then the serpents can't breathe
and come out and get you and that's also
an extremely old story like the notion
that if you ignore
a snake anywhere it'll just grow and
eventually it'll come out of the closet
and get you you know and so the question
well what do you do about that it's like
well you go look for the snakes while
they're still babies and to some degree
that's what we're doing in this
conversation is we're thinking well this
bugs me and this bugs me and I don't
really understand this I don't really
understand that maybe we should discuss
it delineate it unpack it and so then we
can dispense with the problem before it
makes itself manifest at a large scale
and that's why we have a right to free
speech
so first of all we don't have a right to
free speech that's a wrong way of
thinking about it any society that's
going to stabilize itself across time
has to be predicated on the ability of
people to communicate why because that's
how we think
because you might think you go home and
think it's like first of all
don't be thinking you're that good at
thinking
it's really hard to learn how to think
you have to learn how to divide yourself
into several people internally and then
you have to let those people represent
things you don't want to represent and
then you have to let them have a war in
your head and you have to be able to
tolerate that that's really hard and you
probably can't do it there's very few
people who are expert at that it takes
years of training so how do you do it if
you're not able to really think now that
doesn't mean you can't think at all but
don't be thinking you're an expert at it
well you do that by talking to people
that's how you think and then the
question is why do you think well Alfred
North Whitehead said the reason we think
is so that we can let our thoughts die
instead of us
so imagine you have a stupid idea
which is highly profitable right doesn't
matter you might have 50 of them a day
so then you think well let's go act out
that stupid idea which is what you do if
you're an impulsive and so you act out
the stupid idea and you get just
walloped by the world and maybe you die
well so what's an alternative well why
don't you throw your stupid idea out on
the table
to a bunch of other people and say well
I have this idea I'm kind of thinking
about acting it out is it stupid and you
maybe you're prideful about your idea
because you know you're attracted by it
and you thought it up whatever that
means and so now you're glued to it plus
it tiles something for you so you're
invested in it and you don't want it to
be a stupid idea but then like yeah fine
do you want to die or do you want you to
let your idea die
and so a lot of what we do in dialogue
is kill stupid ideas and we do that so
we don't act them out and we don't want
to act them out because then we die and
this even works biologically so the part
of your brain that generates thought
grew out of the part of your brain that
you used to voluntarily control your
actions so you could say a thought is a
potential action people think a thought
is a representation of the world it's
like yeah not fundamentally
fundamentally a thought is a potential
action so then in your imagination you
make avatars of yourself so that's you
and your imagine what if I did this it's
a little Avatar of yourself you think
what if I did this here's the world I
walk I act like this these good things
happen that's my vision then you throw
your vision on the table and you say I
have this vision and you say well that's
a stupid Vision because you didn't take
this into account and how are you going
to do that and you think oh that sucks
because I had this Vision but
well thank you because I didn't see
those snakes you know right and then
It's tricky because maybe you're mad
because I had a vision and you don't
have one and so you're pissed off about
that and so you're just attacking my
vision because you know you don't have
anything better to do and I've had this
conversation with someone before where a
kid told me he wanted like a million
followers on social media yeah and I was
like yeah but that's not gonna happen
though like not for you right because I
knew because I had the experience you
know and then I had that moment where
they basically freaked out right yeah
well you shatter a dream absolutely well
so a dream is a tile of the future so
you say what's the future well you don't
know well here's a vision so that's now
it's a tile and then it covers the
future and it also covers it in a
pleasing way then you come along and say
you know it's a little low res well you
could say to someone who wants that are
you sure you want a million followers
you know because people say I'd be happy
if I had 400 million dollars it's like
you think you could handle that
responsibility do you like you're so
sure that that all of a sudden you'd
have all this money dumped on your you
can't even control your household budget
you live from paycheck to paycheck now
you somebody's going to dump a treasure
on your
steps and that's going to fix your life
it's like okay how much you're going to
give to your relatives
like none oh that'll work out really
well too much
so then you're going to take away their
responsibility from them are you and
you're going to get that balance exactly
right and then what are you going to do
with that money because as soon as you
got the money the parasites are going to
come in and take your money yeah because
I had clients that were helping us
quickly believe me unbelievably
unbelievably quickly and it happens
unbelievably quickly you know you'll see
while the average family fortune last
three generations that's all because
money sitting around not being carefully
monitored it's like water it just it's
just it's happening to me in my life
it's the amount of money I've had you
spent um three family Generations I'm
talking about just it's been quite
something because I came from nothing
yeah and I've I've made amounts of money
that I never dreamed were possible right
and yet I have very little to show for
if I'm being honest with you because
what what culminates around you and how
many people all of a sudden come to the
table and me being a generous soft
natured person they say a fool is easily
probably with his money I feel like a
fool yeah
one thing I do want to actually go back
to because there's certain things about
you that I've always spoken to me
specifically and we're talking about
Lion King earlier and we also haven't
finished uncovering that tweet I do
absolutely yeah but this is important
actually from just for me personally to
bring up because
um Lion King uh Forrest Gump Godfather
Braveheart all my favorite movies
surround about young boy becomes a man
right right that's a Pinocchio story
yeah and the Peter Pan story
thank you there's so many of them and
and me personally my uh relationship
with my dad was difficult growing up he
was in prison all sorts of things happen
where I was I wasn't with him a lot and
my when I hear you talk about uh young
men's search to become a man and it
feels like uh obviously you've got a
huge audience around those uh topics
when you've covered them because so many
men young men especially feel so lost
right now and they're searching for
these answers of how do we get to that
point and I mean it felt it feels like
when I look back in even 50 years ago
that wasn't there the way it is now
that's definitely the case yeah well
when my dad was my dad
was a school teacher he's still alive
and he got disenchanted with School
teaching in part because all of the
authority in his classroom was taken
from him so if there were disciplinary
issues in the class it had to be brought
up the hierarchy to the to the the
administrative echelons above him and so
he he could feel his authority in the
class slipping away and he was quite an
authoritative teacher my dad was my
teacher in grade six
um for math I wasn't in his homeroom but
I remember and by grade six this is
about 12 years old kids are pretty pushy
and fractious you know and 10 minutes
before the class started the first time
my dad walked into the room everyone was
silent
because he had a reputation and the
reputation was don't mess with him and
it wasn't because he was mean you know
he had a he had a hard spine and you
didn't want to push him but he was
authoritative and he also got
disenchanted with television so when he
was young and even when I was young
there were shows like my three sons and
Father Knows Best can you imagine a show
called father's knows best now the
closest I've seen to that recently is is
Ted lasso that's the only sitcom I've
seen for like five gen five decades in
some sense that has a genuinely positive
male lead so kudos to Ted lasso you see
that a little bit in The Simpsons hey
because that's why it was such an
interestingly subversive show because
Homer is a bumbling fool and Marge in
some sense has the moral upper hand but
not entirely but Homer the thing about
Homer is he's trying he's not very
bright but he is trying and he would
like to be a good father and he's
faithful to his wife and and his kids
and so there is this underlying solidity
of that male character but you know it's
damning with faint praise and now young
men they're on under assault for on two
from two directions fundamentally one is
all male Authority is nothing but
patriarchal oppression and so imagine
now you're an ambitious young man which
is the drive to work toward that
Authority well all that is is a
manifestation of the power dynamic in
men that produced the patriarchal
oppressive Colonial tyranny and so now
you're a moral young man you think well
my ambition is
to be
not only to be questioned it's to be
squelched entirely because it's nothing
but a manifestation of power imagine
that maybe you escape from that by some
maneuvering but then there's another
assault that's waiting which is all
human activity is nothing but part of
the force that's devouring the planet
and it's going to put us all in flames
it's like oh good so not only am I part
of the patriarchal oppressive Force but
I'm also the despoiler of Mother Nature
and so if you tell boys that constantly
and you do and then you also say all of
the sexual advances that you make
towards women on any front whatsoever
are to be regarded with extreme
skepticism
and then you feed them pornography on a
Non-Stop basis so there's an easy way
out and that's a unbelievably powerful
that's a drug oh well you know no one
really thinks this through in some sense
but
any 12 year old boy 13 year old boy can
now see more beautiful naked women in 15
minutes than the richest king in history
ever saw in his whole life you think
well you know we don't have to worry
about that it's like yeah you have to
worry about that that's a that's a huge
problem and it's a demoralizing problem
because it offers an easy way out and so
if all of your ambition is nothing but
the junior manifestation of power and
should be squelched out of you as early
as possible and schools do this because
they punish boys for playing so
hyperactivity
looks like suppressed play Behavior so
there's good animal models of that by
the way and you can if you deprive
animals of play especially juvenile male
animals a lot of this has been done with
rats because they're very playful by the
way
if you deprive them of play they'll play
hyperactively when you give them the
opportunity and you can suppress that
with methylphenidate that's Ritalin it
suppresses play Behavior now it focuses
attention
focuses attention attention deficit it's
like no probably not these boys just
need to be out in the playground running
around playing like for more time than
they're allowed with their boisterous
competitive play Behavior you know and
we don't need competition you know all
all games should be cooperative which is
complete rubbish it's not a game if it's
just cooperative and it's such a Dopey
view of cooperation like if you and I
you and I are playing one-on-one
basketball then well are we cooperating
or competing well did you did you bring
a chess board
no you you came to play basketball well
how about that's cooperation we've
decided what the rules are going to be
that's cooperation obviously fundamental
we're playing the same game that's
cooperation think it through and so then
are we competing well
yes but what does that mean it means
well
we're we're getting in each other's way
in some sense while we're trying to hit
the goal
but we're doing that in a way that
improves our skill at hitting the goal
because if you set up an obstacle to me
which is what you do if we're playing
one-on-one basketball you're making it
difficult for me to hit the target and
so that means you're making me better at
hitting the Target and if we do that
optimally then it's fun and you might
say why well the word sin
is derived from a Greek word hamartia
and there's a there's a Jewish
parallel semantic Track by the way that
has the same underlying structure
hamarti is an archery term
it means to miss the target
and so what we're trying to do is hit
the target well what's the target well
that's the question it's a hard question
but we're trying to hit the target and
how do you know
well what are people doing when they're
playing sports
like all sports virtually
are circulate around hitting the target
it might be crossing the Finish Line
first so the target would be being the
fastest among that group so that would
be swimming let's say or it might be
football all of its variants obviously
that's a you're hitting the target
that's what basketball is that's what
shooting is that's what archery is it's
all hitting the Target now we're hunting
creatures we're based on a hunting
platform and we're visual Hunters too
and so we're looking at Targets all the
time and trying to hit them and part of
what we're doing when we're competing is
we set a joint Target and then we set up
an adversarial structure that improve
improves our skill while we practice
hitting the Target and so is that
competition it's like well no it's not
competition in that the goal is to
defeat you even though I'm going to try
to win because otherwise the game's no
fun the real game is can we make each
other better in a sustainable way
so that we can hit the target more
effectively and Men
especially on the sports pitch of course
women do this too but it's it's more of
a masculine Enterprise in some sense
it's a masculine Enterprise not a male
Enterprise not not for men only it's
honing your ability to hit the target
and when you deviate from the target
deviation from the target that's sin
that's what it means it's so useful to
know that it's like
well I missed the mark and then you're
guilty about it well you should be
supposed to hit the mark and what's the
mark well the Mark is the line between
Order and Chaos or the line the Mark is
the the playful engagement in good
conversation the Mark is a really
intense game eh an intense game is
you're serious about it the person per
person is pushing you right to your
bloody limit and vice versa and you want
that in a conversation too and maybe you
want that in a movie you know you want
to be pushed to your limit that's why
people go to horror movies for example
not past your limit because that's
stressful but right on that edge comedy
does that
like a great comedian puts you right can
I say this Jimmy Carr's good at that so
is Bill Burr he's like oh my god do I
have to say this yes here it is
everybody goes oh it's it's so funny
because the laughter is spontaneous and
it's an indication that the person hit
the target and you can't regulate it
because you don't laugh consciously
right you laugh unconsciously and then
the comedian knows hey I hit the target
with that one everybody goes oh yeah I
can't believe you said that someone had
to say it thank God they said it and
then we get enlightened a little bit by
The Comedians and so they hit the target
and they're really good at that so yum
Carl Jung the psychoanalyst said the
fool is the precursor to the savior
why because the fool will tell the truth
right and and you can't redeem yourself
without telling the truth and in the
court so the court might be the place
where the evil King rules
and that's one possibility that the
king's court maybe the evil King is
ruling well you need a fool why well the
Fool's beneath contempt so the fool can
say anything well so is the fool the
fool or the king
because if the fool is the only person
free enough to say anything it's not
obvious that the king is in control it
might be the fools in control that has a
real power but he doesn't have the
responsibility that goes with that well
he has the responsibility to be funny
right okay right yeah so that is a
responsibility it's a responsibility to
tell the truth no he's not he's not the
administrator right but at least he's
the person who's feeding truth into the
culture and certainly comedians do that
one marker of someone you can't trust is
well I have no sense of humor I don't
see why that's funny it's like yeah you
don't that's that's pretty sad we should
there's some things comedians shouldn't
be allowed to make fun of it's like
yeah you're gonna decide that are you
you're going to decide what people get
to think is funny this unconscious
manifestation you're going to regulate
that and you're going to claim
pridefully that well yeah I'm going to
regulate that and things will be a hell
of a lot better because of it it's like
yeah if you're the sort of tyrant that
can't stand if you're the sort of King
that can't stand the fool then you're a
tyrant so that's a great marker for
people to like be leery of one thing I I
was interested to know
is I've never heard you talk about
conspiracy theories and I wonder if any
of them had ever appealed to you where
you were thinking actually well I'm not
I'm not particularly conspiratorial by
temperament but you're investigative so
yeah I just wondered if there was
anything about it well the thing so
conspiracy theories in some sense are
the fantasies of disagreeable people
so disagreeable people are very
skeptical and they think what's going on
behind the scenes and so they and then
some of them get a little on the
psychotic end and so they have quite a
wide fantasy networks they get paranoid
so when disagreeable people become
psychotic they get paranoid and so then
you might say well
you know what do they say just because
you're paranoid doesn't mean that no one
is after you which I really love and the
thing about paranoid people is well
sometimes they're right
you know so they produce a lot of behind
the scenes theories and
who what two percent of the time they're
on Target and so it's kind of useful to
keep an eye on the conspiracy theories
because
they're the most skeptical people who
are using the most fantasy now the and
so they're creative in a sense they're
creative in this sort of disagreeable
way the thing about creating or
describing Alex Jones basically in a way
there's lots of people like that and
they're worth attending to because now
and then they dig up a nugget you know
and so but but a lot of it's noise and
not signal and this is actually the
problem with creativity is that
creativity is absolutely necessary
but most ideas are stupid and
destructive
so like what do we do with that because
zero creativity means you can't adapt
nothing changes but everything changes
so you better change with it but how
fast and the answer is well the creative
person takes won't change this and
change this and change this and
radically transform that and here's a
good idea it's like
maybe sometimes one of those ideas would
work incrementally better
but probably not probably they just
upset everything so you've got to be
unbelievably judicious in relationship
to creative ideas and the same thing
works on the paranoid front it's like
so and you need rules about that so one
rule is don't assume malevolence when
stupidity is sufficient explanation
Boris Johnson and that it's a really
good it's a really good rule because
stupidity ignorance let's say and I
don't even mean willful blindness I mean
just the fact that people don't know
what the hell they're doing that
accounts for so many problems that you
can hardly even believe it and then you
could add willful blindness to that
which is people's refusal to look at
something they know they should look at
but don't and then you can add some
malevolence in there and all of those
are a factor but one of the ways to
protect yourself against conspiratorial
thinking is to give some do Credence to
ignorance like people make lots of
mistakes because they just don't know
any better and then they make some
mistakes because they won't look and
then they make some mistakes because
they're trying to cause trouble The
conspiratorial Thinker jumps right to
malevolence and and and and and and
willful blindness it says well you know
you're willfully blind and you're
malevolent it's like well to yes a bit
yes but not completely and mostly I'm
just stupid you know if I get an
argument with my wife and this happens
we have a relative fractious
relationship you know although
fundamentally it's peaceful because we
sort things out but
she'll sometimes well me too with her
I'll think
what she's trying to hurt my feelings
maybe maybe that's a way of thinking
about it's like or I'm trying to hurt
her feelings or I'm not paying attention
properly it's like no I'm just too
stupid to know what you want and we've
really sort of figured this out it's
really strange one of my first questions
were was going to be something about
like why the [__] are women such hard
bloody work yes well they're their hard
work I can tell I can tell you why to
some degree we don't know what the [__]
they want women are on average
experience more negative emotion than
men so 75 percent of divorces are
initiated by women and women are more
unhappy than men and so they're more
prone to depression and they're more
prone to anxiety disorders they're more
prone to suicide attempts although men
commit suicide more often because they
use guns because men tend to be more
violent even towards themselves men are
very decisive on them yeah yeah well
that's yes in nature wants their minds
yes yes yes yes so so women are higher
negative emotion and and so why well it
kicks in at puberty and so why would
women become more sensitive to threat at
puberty well let's figure it out it's
pretty straightforward they're at a
physical disadvantage because boys and
girls can wrestle and fight but men and
women can't so men are way stronger
especially in the upper body and so
women hit men more than the reverse by a
lot yeah so you might say well are women
or men more violent well if it's just
blows struck women win but if there's
blows that land yeah right okay right
exactly and the women know that so they
know they can give you a cough and it's
like well
wait there's two more things okay so
women get comparatively weak or
physically so the world's more dangerous
okay then they're more vulnerable
sexually right then they have to take
care of infants so they're tilted
towards more threat detection and so
that makes them
it makes them maybe sub-optimally happy
when you think about them as individuals
because they're always aware of all of
these threats so it's harder for them to
switch off whereas yeah when I walk down
the street I'm not worried yeah in the
same way yeah of course of course this
has been really something and I would
love to have you back on next time
you're in London uh truly uh an
individual in the world and someone
who's bringing interest in things so how
would you like to be remembered I'd like
to be remembered as alive
yeah yeah
um people have asked me that before I
mean I'd I'd like to be remembered I
suppose as someone who was encouraging
because that's what I think primarily
I'm doing is encouraging people it's
like yeah yeah you're full of problems
and you're massive snakes and all that
and but fundament not fundamentally
you're the thing that can handle snakes
fundamentally so if you would be willing
to and so and I really I not only do I
believe that in some sense I I know it's
true I know it's true
so I'm trying to tell people that it's
like yeah your sad case
but uh
but there's a hell of a lot more to you
than you think like way more enough to
cope with the trouble of the world
inside you there's enough to cope with
the trouble of the world and you if you
had enough courage you could let that
out enough courage and Faith you could
you could let that out and everything
would be better because of it really
really
and so that's a good that's a good story
and it's also true and so I'm trying to
tell that story
so keep shining your light on on the
snacks I do like that uh that was Jordan
Peterson on the true Jordan podcast uh
obviously they can go and find out where
you're going to be or is there a website
that you prefer yeah well they can go to
jordanbpeterson.com and my tour is
scheduled their list of recommended
books um so if you want to Enlighten
yourself on the intellectual side I have
100 books there if you spent three years
reading them
you'd be a much sharper uh knife in the
drawer let's say okay and uh yeah so
people are welcome to do that I have a
couple of online programs at self
authoring.com and understandmyself.com
and the latter is a personality test
that'll outline your strengths and
weaknesses very accurately and if you do
that with your partner you get a report
that tells you where you're compatible
and where you're not and why or your
business partner maybe or your business
partner absolutely we're gonna we're
gonna modify the site so that Fathers
and Sons can do it and mothers and
daughters and business partners you
should make a dating up because yeah we
thought about that not very good so yeah
well it'd be nice to be reasonably
matched temperamentally with your
potential partner I mean just be a
series of dates of guys talking to women
about what Carl Jung said though
podcast big thank you I appreciate it
and we'll see you on the next one nice
to meet you guys thanks for the
invitation and thanks to all you who are
listening and watching as well yeah much
appreciated